[Music]
the loud house characters show the
amusing dynamics of a large family the
eleven siblings all come with unique and
completely different personalities and
today we'll check out what these
characters would look like as a Disney
Princess yes we even managed to find a
few versions of Lincoln don't forget to
like this video and subscribe to our
channel if you're a fan of the loud
house now let's look at ten loud house
characters reimagined as Disney
Princesses Lin the 13 year old Lin is
definitely an interesting character and
the loud family wouldn't be the same
without her if you have a competitive
sibling you know what it's like and can
probably relate to the rest of the loud
family Lin will want to beat you and
just about everything but on the plus
side she's extremely good at sports
she's usually seen wearing a sporty
outfit but we've managed to find a few
versions of Lin looking like a Disney
Princess can you imagine her in a
beautiful Cinderella dressed like that
she looks absolutely wonderful we also
found this fantastic Lin Cinderella
illustration made by a deviantART user
PR storm he even added luan as a
prankster woman and we can imagine that
if the loud house ever makes a crossover
with Disney this is exactly what would
happen we always love seeing the 1 and
Lin interact as they each get on each
other's nerves just as much as they
actually get along while Lin would play
Cinderella the fourteen-year-old luan
would probably pretend she's a fairy
godmother and would end up totally
pranking and embarrassing her isn't that
what older sisters are for anyways
speaking of annoying and embarrassing
sisters did you know that the original
version of the cartoon featured a boy
rabbit with twenty five rabbits sisters
imagined all those rabbits looking like
a Disney Princess we dare a talented
deviant art user to make it happen
Lola when we talk about princesses we
have to include the pageant Queen
herself
the six-year-old Lola reminds us of
Alana Thompson from here comes honey boo
boo the to not only have similar
mannerisms but they actually kind of
look alike well today we'll check out
what Lola would look like as an actual
Disney princess
and since we're pretty sure Lola will
want to look a lot better than any
Disney Princess out there we found some
original designs that would definitely
suit
pageant queen she might not be a
mallanna or Rapunzel but her character
would definitely add some spice to the
life of a Disney Princess deviantART
user called shreds reimagined her in a
unique Disney way although we have to
admit her long hair does remind us of
Rapunzel she definitely looks much
calmer than the original hyperactive
Lola we know from the loud house we also
managed to find this totally awesome
illustration which belongs to danmaku
monde now this looks more like it this
version of Lola definitely reminds us of
the hyperactive six-year-old but at the
same time she also looks like Aurora in
that pink dress she's rocking her blond
hair and we love her missing tooth did
you know Lola was named after the
creators wiener dog she definitely looks
a lot more glamorous than any wiener dog
we know Luna moving on to one of our
favorite rock stars ever we have to
admit that Luna is one of our favorite
loud house siblings even though we feel
like we really shouldn't pick favorites
you just have to love the stylish 15
year old who loves to hum some of our
favorite rock songs Luna is definitely a
unique character and a little bit
different from the rest of her siblings
when it comes to her looks we love her
chill attitude we've previously showed
you what she would look like as the
opposite gender and as a body builder
but Luna as a Disney princess is our
favorite combination check her out
doesn't this look like Rapunzel's dress
but of course in Lunas unique rock style
it was created by a talented deviantART
user called ec 707 who brilliantly
reinvented the traditional tiara and we
can't even imagine seeing Luna with long
hair like Rapunzel's this definitely
suits her original style speaking of the
original style of Luna you probably
already know that the loud house
characters were originally created as
rabbits but did you know that Lunas name
came from the creator's wiener dog Chris
Sava knows mother-in-law had a dog named
Luna which is what inspired this
cartoons characters named Luna seems so
relaxed we're pretty sure she wouldn't
mind that she's named after a dog
anyways rock on Luna Lennie
it looks like the fabulous Lennie just
became extra fabulous the 16 year old
Lennie is the fashion
two of the family and although she's one
of the most naive characters we've ever
seen she's also extremely loving and
protective over her brother and sisters
we love her happy-go-lucky personality
and even though she's one of the oldest
siblings she never shows off her
dominance like her older sister
well we found Linney reimagined as the
older Disney sister Elsa and she can
definitely pull off this look the first
drawing was done by a talented
deviantART user who put Linney in the
cute Elsa dress of course Leni being the
ditzy girl she is she's totally singing
the wrong song here's another version
created by Logan Watcher although she
doesn't have her iconic white sunglasses
you can definitely tell this is Lenny
and it looks like she could really pull
off the Elsa look Lenny was lucky unlike
the two of her other sisters she
actually got her name from Chris
savino's real sister he comes from a
large family so we can imagine some of
his sisters actually act like the
characters we see on the show we'd love
to see the real-life Lenny dressed as
Elsa and singing part of your world from
The Little Mermaid for no apparent
reason
Lana the six year old Lana is a complete
opposite from her princess pageant twin
sister Lola
we love Lana's tomboyish look and the
fact that she would rather play with mud
than wear anything pink or girly kissy
Lou on deviantART reimagined both Lana
and Lola as Disney Princesses and made
Lana a pretty cute Mulan the look
definitely goes with her tomboyish
nature and Lana or should we say Moo
Lana seems to also love animals we can
definitely see Lana portraying a
princess that fits her own personality
Mulan definitely seems to be the one
that she would choose we also found this
cute drawing done by Mike Eddie admirer
89 it's Lana dressed as Princess Lola
who seems to be wearing a Rapunzel dress
unlike her twin sister Lana wasn't named
after a wiener dog her name belongs to
Kris savino's actual sister and we
really want to know if she loves to play
in the mud as much as Lana does we did
find out that although Kris used his
sister's names he didn't really base the
characters off of their personalities
however we'd like to imagine that some
of his sisters wear a tomboyish as Lana
is as much as we love Lana as a disney
princess we really adore her tomboy look
and the fact that she dares to be
different from her much girlier twin
sister
let's talk about the only boy in the
family and yes we did manage to find
some illustrations of him as a Disney
Princess the 11 year old Lincoln has a
tough job in front of him as he tries to
live with his 10 sisters if you come
from a big family
you know there are definitely ups and
downs when it comes to being the only
boy or the only girl we've seen Lincoln
share his distaste in the fact that he
has so many sisters but he also soon
learns how lucky he is that all his
sisters are protective of him we found
one of the coolest versions of Lincoln
as a Disney Princess check it out
it was created by a deviant art user
called SB 99 stuff and it's absolutely
amazing this is Lanie loud but we also
see some inspiration from Aurora's hair
and Jasmine and Cinderella's dress we
also found this version of Lincoln as a
girl and he definitely looks like he's a
Disney princess in training Lincoln's
white hair comes from the original loud
house characters which were initially
rabbits but do you know how he got his
name Chris Savino loves to pull
inspiration from his life and Lincoln's
name came from the street where Chris
lived on as a child
Lincoln's definitely our favorite and we
can't wait to see more of him in future
episodes Lisa we're really having a hard
time picking our favorite characters
from the loud house but we can say that
lisa is pretty high up on our list
although she's only four years old lisa
is one of the smartest characters on the
show she can easily skip grades and she
even won a Nobel Peace Prize her
experiments often get her in trouble and
she even managed to connect the world of
The Fairly OddParents with the loud
house she's a lot like her six-year-old
sister Lana and we hardly ever see her
dressed in skirts or wearing any dresses
we did manage to find Lisa in a dress
and we're totally in love doesn't she
resemble Princess Tiana from The
Princess and the Frog in that green
dress we can definitely see Tiana share
a few personality traits with Lisa it
wouldn't be the first time Lisa would
connect to cartoon worlds together and
we'd love to see her turn everyone
including herself into a Disney Princess
for a single episode the Disney world
definitely needs to see a princess act
as intelligent and sarcastic as Lisa
come on Nickelodeon let's make that
story happen Lisa's name was also
inspired by Chris savino's actual sister
and we wonder if she was just as
intelligent at four years old as this
wonder child Louann one of the
characters that we definitely don't see
fit in with the rest of the typical
Disney princess world is the
fourteen-year-old prankster Louann you
can bet on Louann to be the sister that
always cranks up the jokes and puns and
even though nobody in her family is
laughing we find her totally hilarious
we did find her this illustration done
by cartoon admirer on deviantART which
shows what LuAnn would look like as
Belle from Beauty and the Beast yellow
is definitely LuAnn signature color so
we can definitely see this work we've
also come across this drawing of LuAnn
as a medieval entertainer created by sip
vampire master 27 on tumblr this role is
definitely more suitable for a comical
character like LuAnn I found although
Princess Daisy is actually from Super
Mario we thought you might enjoy seeing
LuAnn dressed up as Princess Daisy and
telling jokes to the mushrooms
we're pretty sure LuAnn would actually
be the funniest princess ever and we
really want to see it happen as
interesting as her name appears to be
LuAnn was actually one of the names of
Chris savino's five sisters and if she
can crack as many jokes as LuAnn can we
are officially jealous of Chris's family
Laurie Laurie might be the oldest in the
group but she can definitely leave her
siblings feeling frustrated as she loves
to point out the fact that she's older
while she is still protective over her
siblings the 17 year old Laurie spends a
lot of time on the phone talking to her
boyfriend Bobby even so she's still an
important character in the loud house
and we found quite a few versions of
Laurie looking like a perfect as knee
princess check these out this princess
Laurie belongs to Batman messer 609 on
deviantART the illustration features
Laurie's typical blue outfit and it
reminds us of something Cinderella might
wear here is that same Cinderella blue
dress again showing that Laurie can
definitely rock a princess look this
design belongs to EC 707 on deviantART
and the last image belongs to Casey Lou
and shows off quite a few of the loud
house siblings in their Disney version
Laurie of course is the one dressed up
as Ariel from The Little Mermaid sitting
on
a statue even though lorry is the oldest
she definitely isn't the most mature her
personality is similar to Lenny's
although lorry is a little bit more
assertive her name also comes from one
of Kriss savvy nose sisters if you've
ever had an older sibling you probably
heard them bragging that they're older
at least once in your childhood and if
you are an older sibling you know
exactly why Laurie loves teasing her
brothers and sisters Lucy well it's
almost impossible to find Lincoln
dressed as a Disney Princess we've also
struggled to find designs that really
managed to capture Lucy's persona Lucy
represents the dark face several of us
have gone through in our childhood
she's always seen in dark clothing and
she's not known to have an interest in
anything her siblings are up to
however despite Lucy's dark demeanor we
managed to find quite a few versions of
what Lucy would look like as a Disney
Princess of course she's totally unique
since Disney Princesses are known to
wear bright clothing that's definitely
not Lucy style check her out here she is
in the back in black episode reminding
us of Cinderella a deviantART user see
Bart reimagined her in a cute black
dress she looks like she could easily
play a Disney character called the
princess of darkness and here's the
illustration by kissy Lou who turned
Lucy into jasmine and Snow White
she even included the Seven Dwarves Lucy
looks way more impressed flying on a
magic carpet than she does holding that
red Apple doesn't she her name was also
inspired by one of Chris savino's
sisters but we can imagine the real-life
Lucy is slightly less moody than this
loud house character and even though she
sometimes scares us we can't deny that
the loud family wouldn't be the same
without Lucy would you ever make a
cartoon show about your own family give
us an example of what your own episodes
would look like in the comments that's
it for ten loud house characters
reimagined as Disney Princesses if you
love the loud house make sure to check
out ten loud house characters all grown
up see you next time
[Music]